[Aplausos]
[Música]
a los 20 años fue mis primeros juegos
centroamericanos y el caribe nos
encontrábamos en la final de tenis en
dobles contra puerto rico y vamos arriba
con mucha ventaja ya un punto de la
medalla de oro
perdí ese punto clave y de ahí no nos
volvemos a recuperar pero lo más
interesante fue mi mente se enganchó se
enganchó en ese punto clave en los
hubieras en la medalla de oro del
entrenador que estaba muy enojado en mi
coraje e impotencia
era una enredadera de pensamientos nunca
logré callar mi mente para volver al
partido es más no recuerdo ni un solo
punto después
estar a punto es un orgullo para méxico
acabamos siendo criticadas por nuestros
directivos con bulas como por eso las
mujeres están hechas para cocinar
de ahí sería un año bien difícil lleno
de entrenamientos duros y muchas
derrotas
me fui hundiendo poco a poco en
frustración y desconfianza sin saber
cómo salir y lo que más me hacía feliz
empezó a darme miedo y eso se empezó a
apoderar de mí
estamos de acuerdo que si no existe el
miedo tampoco existe el coraje
cuando estamos en un estado de
insatisfacción el miedo no nos deja
cambiarlo y eso nos frustra provocando
más insatisfacción y la verdad y ya
estaba harta de todo eso
estaba jugando en pueblo las gradas
estaban totalmente llenas y no la vamos
eso ahí estaban mis papás no me habían
visto competir en un año y como en otras
ocasiones iba arriba y estaba a un punto
de ganar
un error aquí otro allá se me empezó a
ir de las manos me enredé en mis
pensamientos y lo perdí
lo lamentable es que mi reacción fue la
que ya se me había convertido en un
hábito aventar la raqueta en esta
ocasión fue con todas mis fuerzas y no
me pregunten cómo pero rebotó y salió
disparada las gradas pegándole una
señora
la gente empezó a chiflar y abusar
recuerdo haber un señor gritar no la
veréis la raqueta formación
no recuerdo más solo que me gustaban
hasta salir de la cancha me abuchearon a
mí a la mexicana a la que estaban ahí
para apoyar
después fue a buscar a la señora para
pedir una disculpa y ahí estaba fábrica
y contó derecho 15 el guamazo que se
llevó la pobre pero lo que más coraje le
dio es que su hija que estaba al lado de
ella lo había visto todo me dijo que su
hija me miraba mucho y que la había
desilusionado
ahí me cayó el veinte que me pasó en qué
momento me convertí en una vergüenza
tenía una responsabilidad como educadora
deportiva en mi área de influencia
aunque ese no era mi propósito y aquí yo
entrenaba mi cuerpo todos los días para
hacer la mejor tenista que pudiera hacer
pero el plan de dios para mi vida era
mucho más grande que solo eso
el tenista thomas muster a sus 22 años
estaba haciendo historia y después de
salido entrevista tras ganar la
semifinal se fue a su carro y mientras
metía su mochila en la cajuela un
conductor que venía tomado lo impactó a
toda velocidad
los ligamentos de la rodilla izquierda
fueron rebajados y su cuerpo estaba
lleno de contusiones
pero la voluntad y la fuerza mental
fueron sus armas principales para
recuperarse una siguiente que estuvo a
punto de acabar con su carrera
lo operaron y le diseñaron una
maquinaria especial para su rodilla para
que pudiera entrenar y él se aferró a
esa maquinaria como un ciego a su perro
guía mientras una máquina las pelotas le
servía de rival imaginario
muster dijo volver a golpear una pelota
fue una sensación tan agradable como
volver a ganar un torneo él vivía cada
paso al máximo
los médicos habían pronosticado que
pasarían al menos 10 meses antes de que
él pudiera pisar una cancha pero lo hizo
cuatro meses antes y no nomás eso iba a
ser el mejor jugador del mundo
es un caso extraordinario pero así como
el todos aquí tenemos retos y desafíos
que hay que superar y de nuestra mente
depende como los manejamos
mientras fui parte de la selección
mexicana tuvimos el privilegio de
trabajar con ricardo sala un preparador
mental
con él aprendí cómo es que funciona la
mente y entendí cómo la podemos usar
para lograr nuestros objetivos
él nos explicó como el que practica la
parte mental y espiritual llega a
valorar el arte de concentración
relajada más que cualquier otra
habilidad también descubre una verdadera
base para la confianza y aprende que el
secreto está en no intentarlo con tantas
ganas
se trata de lograr un desempeño
espontáneo que solo pasan cuando la
mente y alma están en calma y parecen
formar una unidad con el cuerpo así el
cuerpo encuentra sorprendentes maneras
para ir más allá de sus límites una y
otra vez
esto lo podemos ver todos en nuestras
vidas diarias aquí les va un ejemplo
a todos nos ha pasado que vamos
manejando del trabajo a nuestra casa por
la misma ruta que tomamos todos los días
te distraes y cuando menos te das cuenta
ya estás en tu casa
no hay vas pensando literalmente en cada
maniobra que hiciste pero puedes tenerlo
por seguro que maneja esté mejor que
nunca
eso es porque dejaste que tu
inconsciente tomara cargo de algo que ya
sabes que será automáticamente como lo
es caminar en este caso manejar
eso es concentración relajada
piccardo sala lo describe así la mente
es un órgano de reflejos inconscientes
llena tu mente de millones de reflejos
al día y logrará la sabiduría de
millones de actividades
estrictamente hablando no podemos hacer
dos cosas a la vez con la atención o sea
conscientemente yo sé que todas las
mujeres aquí van a decir que si pueden
pero en realidad no podemos caminar y
hablar a la vez o incluso para agregar
una tercera tarea como escuchar música y
una cuarta como comernos una nieve pero
eso se trata de programas automáticos
que se hacen sin apenas presta la
atención en otras palabras solo el
inconsciente trabaja pero la cosa cambia
cuando queremos hacer una tarea que ya
dominamos y el consciente siempre está
atención e interfiere bombardeándonos
con pensamientos e instrucciones
pero hacemos al ejemplo de una tarea
simple que ya dominamos como lo es
caminar pero en este caso lo estás
haciendo en un escenario en donde miles
de personas te van a ver pasar y tú
consciente presta atención y empieza no
te vas a tropezar
camina más rápido no tan rápido va lento
aquatech el oeste
y hay mucha gente que nervioso ya me
quiero ir
este chavo que me gusta me veré jorobada
endereza te mete la panza etcétera y
mientras tanto camina raro incómodo
hasta te sientes descoordinado
impidiendo que las cosas fluyan y cómo
logras callar al consciente
la asignación a tarea
ok entendiendo que tenemos dos mentes
consciente e inconsciente y que tienen
distintas tareas imagínate que te
acuestas a ver una película y tienes a
un niño al lado de repente te empieza
hacer preguntas y te perdías de algunas
partes después se para jugar y se
atraviese enfrente de la pantalla o la
apaga una y otra vez hasta crisis el
niño ven siéntate aquí conmigo y además
te rompecabezas
al niño no lo más castigado a su cuarto
ni lo reprimen simplemente le asignas
una tarea y así tú puedes disfrutar de
la película y del momento agradable que
estás buscando
de hecho niño va a acabar de almadrones
de cabezas y se va a volver para hacer
su parte hacer preguntas a jugar a
interferir
entonces tú le asignas una tarea más
difícil un rompecabezas más complicado
quién está viendo la película en la
analogía de la mente inconsciente y
quién es el niño la mente consciente va
a llegar un momento dado en donde no va
a entender que lo que tú quieres es ver
la película
después de algunos estudios descubrí que
yo era muy visual y una herramienta
práctica que me ayudó a callar mis
pensamientos en el tenis fue ver la
pelota pero el 100 por ciento desde que
la recogía la votaba con mira que está y
le veía literalmente cada detalle como
giraba la pelusa las costuras la marca
el número todo después me la pasaba la
mano y la giraba pero mi vista con el
mismo enfoque y durante el punto lo
mismo le veía literalmente cada detalle
hasta impactar la y cómo viajaba hacia
la raqueta del contrincante y volvía una
y otra vez
eso callaba mi mente
en el 2009 mi compañero y yo estábamos
en el abierto mexicano de tenis en
acapulco y nos enfrentamos a las
sembradas número 2 del evento una
húngara y una chica
la verdad en teoría serán mucho mucho
mejores que nosotros nadie nos daba
esperanzas de ganar de hecho empezamos
bien abajo el marcador no se estaban
haciendo garras pero recuerdo buscar
enfocarnos en cada punto sin pensar en
lo que ya había pasado y en lo que podía
pasar y en los miles de pensamientos que
le pueden venir no a la cabeza
simplemente utilizando nuestras
herramientas para estar en el presente
un punto a la vez
de repente ganamos algunos puntos claves
nos fuimos recuperando y las gradas se
empezaron a llenar llevamos el partido
una muerte súbita decisiva y aparece
entonces las gradas estaban totalmente
llenas y así imaginarán las porras
mexicanas
todo lo que aprendimos en cuanto al
enfoque mental lo pudimos aplicar a esa
situación que parece imposible
acabamos ganando ese partido siendo la
primera pareja de mexicanas en dobles en
ganar una ronda en este torneo en la
nota de y es bien nos titularon las
cenicientas
momentos así y cada vez que logré callar
mi mente para mí fue como regreso a la
cancha de muster aunque en como mérito
parezca en menor escala en práctica fue
la culminación de años de pelear contra
mí misma y la habilidad mental
así es que en cualquier plan de vida que
tengamos ya sea nuestro trabajo o en
cualquier deporte o ejercicio que
hagamos o en cualquier situación diaria
recordemos que dejaremos de ser esclavos
de nuestras emociones cuando seamos los
amos de nuestra mente
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]